انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نصائب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
ترقب لمحاكمه ترامب في نيويورك بعد غد
والرئيس السابق يريد المثول امام المحكمه
مقيدا استعراضا لقوته
تسع دول تعلن تخفيضا طوعيا بواقع مليون
و600 الف برميل نفط يوميا ابتداء من مايو
وحتى نهايه العالم
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعترض مسيره انطلقت من
سوريا واجتازت الحدود الشماليه
رغم محاولات ريجيسوناك انعاشه قطاع العمله
المشفره في بريطانيا يختنق بضغط من البنوك
[موسيقى]
اوقتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على موعد مع حدث تاريخي
يوم الثلاثاء انطلاق اول محاكمه لرئيس
امريكي سابق في قضيه جنائيه الموضوع يتعلق
بالجلسه الاولى من المحاكمه الجنائيه
لرئيس الجمهوري السابق دونالد ترامب في
قضيه دفع اموال للممثله الاباحيه ستورمي
دانييلز وذلك من اجل شراء صمتها
[تصفيق]
اذا حاله من التاهب تسود مدينه نيويورك
قبل متولي ترامب امام المحكمه لتوجيه
التهمه اليه بهذا الخصوص امرت شرطه
المدينه 36 الف رجل امن بارتداء زيهم
والاستعدادي للانتشار في المدينه وحول
محكمه من هاتن وخا مكتب المدعي العام وذلك
لمده اسبوع كامل تفاديا لحدوث اي اعمال
خارجه عن النص
حال استنفار القصوى تعرف مدينه نيويورك
اذا حيث تم ايضا وضع حواجز معدنيه حول
محكمه الجنايات في منهات غير ان المحاكمه
في منهات لم ترك كثيرا للفريق القانوني
لترامب الذي يفكر في طلب نقل قضيته
الجنائيه من منهاتن الى جزيره ستاتين في
نيويورك لماذا يا ترى
عن احتمال تحويلها من منهات الى ستايتن
الفريق القانوني لترامب يفكر بالامر خوفا
من عدم حصوله على محاكمه عادله المحامون
ما يزالون يقلبون الفكره لكن لماذا ستيتن
اولا انما بين من هات والستيتن ليس مجرد
خليج يفصلهما
وانما قصه نصر في الانتخابات
بالنسبه لبايدن فان من هاتم هي التي حقق
فيها فوزا كاسحا في 2020 اما ستايتن فهي
التي تفوق فيها ترامب بهامش سبع وخمسين في
المئه اي ان فريق ترامب وبحسب المصادر
يعتقد انه سيجد محلفين محتملين اكثر وديه
وقالت مدعيه فيدراليه السابقه ان السبب
المعتاد للمطالبه بنقل المحاكمه دليل على
انه من المستحيل العثور على 12 محلفا
محيدا
مضيفه ان اي محاوله لنقل المكان من
المحتمل ان تفشل لان المتهمين لا يحق لهم
البحث عن هيئه محلفين بناء على خصائص
محدده يجدونها اكثر ملائمه
فماذا ينتظر ترامب يوم الثلاثاء من
المرتقب يبدا المشهد الاول بدخول ترامبي
للمحكمه عبر مدخل خاص وبمجرد دخوله سيتم
اخذ بصمات اصابعه ثم التقاط صور لوجهه في
اوضاع مختلفه مثل جميع المتهمين في
القضايا الجنائيه وسينتظر ترامب بعد ذلك
في منطقه احتجاز او زنزانه حتى مثوله امام
القاضي كما ستكون المرافعه متاحه لحضور
الجمهور ووفقا لشبكه
اكثر من 30 تهمه تتعلق بالاحتيال التجاري
في لائحه الاتهامات
وفي خضم هذه القضيه تطرح تساؤلات حول ما
اذا كان سيسمح لترامب بخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه في حال حكم عليه بالسجق
يمكن للشرط ان يخوض السباق الانتخابيه من
خلف القطبان
وهناك سابقه تعود للجزء الاول من القرن
العشرين
يجين فيكتور السجين رقم 9653
سياسي من الحزب الاشتراكي الامريكي
ترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه خمس مرات منذ
عام 19
[موسيقى]
نظام التجنيد الاجباري خلال الحرب
العالميه الاولى فسجن
ولكنه ترشح لانتخابات 1920
حاز على اكثر من 913 الف صوت
وكان هذا اكثر عدد اصوات حصل عليها في
مسيرته السياسيه
لكنه لم يفز بالانتخابات ولم يصبح رئيسا
قبل
رجعا يوجين فيكتور بعفو رئاسي في ديسمبر
عام 1921
مشاهدينا قبل ان نتابع في موضوع الان خبر
عاجلا انباء عن غارات اسرائيليه في محيط
مطار دمشق الدولي نذهب الى نيويورك الان
معنا من هناك مراسلنا طلال الحاج طلال
اهلا بك ما الذي رصتهم من مظاهر استعداد
امني خصوصا لمثل ترامب امام القاضي يوم
الثلاثاء
بالفعل الاجراءات الامنيه مشدده جدا تعرف
اليوم هو الاحد عطله نهايه الاسبوع ولكن
نتوقع ان ترتفع الوتيره من ابتداء من الغد
هنا في هذه الساحه تكون هناك مظاهره تم
الترتيب لها من قبل الجمهوريين
ونتوقع اعداد كبيره ولكن المظاهره الكبرى
ستكون يوم الثلاثاء عندما يمثل ترامب امام
القاضي هنا في هذه المحكمه ورائي في
الصوره
وسماع الادله او او التهم الموجهه اليه
نعتقد يطلب عدم قراءتها داخل هذه الجلسه
المقتضبه لن تطور عشر دقائق او ما شابه
وبعد ذلك يتوجه الى مالوراجو بطائرته
الخاصه وسيتكلم
الثلاثاء من مالو لارجو مخاطبا
مؤيد
القضيه لجمع
طلال عذرا اعتذر منك ومن المشاهدين هناك
يعني صوت صدر عن الارسال اذا شكرا جزيلا
لك طلال الحاج مباشره من نيويورك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في اثنتي عشره دقيقه ثماني دول من تعلن عن
سلسله تخفيضات طوعيه في الانتاج حيث قادت
السعوديه خفضا طوعيا منسقا للانتاج النفطي
من دولنا داخل خارجها ايضا ليضاف لها
تمديد روسيا لخفضها المعلن سابقا ليصل
اجمالي الخفض الى مليون و60 الف برميل
يوميا بدءا من مايو المقبل وحتى نهايه
العام الجاري
قادت السعوديه خفضا طوعيا منسقا للانتاج
النفطي من دول داخل اوبيك ومن خارجها
باجمالي مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا بدءا
من مايو المقبل وحتى نهايه العام الجاري
وفسرت الخطوه بانها اجراء احترازي لتحقيق
الاستقرار والتوازن في اسواق الخام وفي
التفاصيل ستخفض السعوديه انتاجها من النفط
ب 500 الف برميل يوميا فيما ستخفض
الامارات الانتاج ب 144 الف برميل يوميا
والكويت ب128 الف برميل يوميا كما اعلنت
الجزائر خفضا طوعيا بثمانيه واربعين الف
برميل يوميا كذلك اعلن العراق انه سيخفض
الانتاج ب 2011 الف برميل يوميا فيما
اعلنت سلطنه عمان خفضا باربعين الف برميل
يوميا كذلك اعلنت كازاخستان عن خفض طوعي
بانتاجها
يوميا فيما اعلنت الجابون عن خفض بثمانيه
الاف برميل يوميا وفي موسكو اعلن نائب
رئيس الوزراء الروسيه
ان بلاده ستمدد خفضا طوعيا بانتاجها من
النفط بواقع 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العمل جاري من متوسط مستوى الانتاج
وفقا لتقييمات مصادر ثانويه لشهر فبراير
وسيضاف هذا الخفض الى الخفض الذي اعلنه
تحالف اوبي بلس في اكتوبر 2022 والذي قضى
بخفض بمليوني برميل يوميا حتى نهايه العام
الجاري هذا وكانت اسعار النفط قد تراجعت
الشهر الماضي الى ادنى مستوى لها في 15
شهرا بالقرب من 70 دولار للبرميل وصفه
ازمه المصارف الامريكيه وتدخل الحكومه
السويسريه لانقاذ كريدي سويس ما يجري ديني
العربيه
معنا من عمان عمار شوبكي الباحث في شؤون
النفط والطاقه استاذ عامر اهلا بك معنا ما
اهميه هذه القرارات بخفض الانتاج الطوعي
من هذه الدول في اوبك في بلاس من حيث
التوقيت بالاساس وكذلك
اهميه القرار بالنسبه للاسواق وسعر برميل
النفط في هذه المرحله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه صهيب هذا
القرار مهم مفاجئ للاسواق مهم جدا بالنسبه
لقراءه
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه العالميه في الفتره
القادمه هو يقرا ان الاقتصاد العالمي
سيشهد تدهورا في الفتره القادمه لذلك كان
استباقيا لتخفيض الانتاج لموازنه العرض مع
الطلب في الاسواق العالميه
واستقرار الحفاظ على استقرار اسواق النفط
هذا الامر بدات ان اوبيكا بلس تقراه اكثر
من مؤسسه الدوليه في الماضي كان قراءتها
قراءه
لحجم الطلب العالمي تقريبا كان الادق من
المؤسسات الدوليه الاخرى وحتى الماليه
وحتى المؤسسات مثل صندوق النقد الدولي
لذلك اتوقع بان قرات اسواق جيدا لهذا جاء
التخفيض الان بهذا الكم الكبير 5 ماذا
نتوقع استاذ عامر غدا مع افتتاح الاسواق
يعني اسعار النفط على الفتره الماضيه شهدت
الكثير من التقلبات ما هي توقعاتك بعد هذه
القرارات بهذا الخفض الطوعي من دول بلس
نعم يعني اسعار النفط كان
اسرع في الشهر مارس الماضي لذلك مع القرار
الحالي اتوقع ان يكون هنالك صدمه في
البدايه في الاسواق ارتفاع على اسعار
النفط ربما يتجاوز العشره دولار
للبرميل يعني تكون في الفتره القادمه
اسعار في التسعينات من الدولارات لكل
برميل لذلك الاسواق في البدايه ستقرا هذه
الاجراءات كصدبه خاصه بعد ان تعلن اوبيك
بلس في اجتماع الوزاري غدا عن هذه
التخفيضات بشكل رسمي الان التخفيضات اعلنت
بشكل فرادى من الدول الثمانيه بالاضافه
الى روسيا غدا سيتم الاعلان بشكل رسمي
وستتلقى الاسواق هذا بارتفاع على اسعار
النفط ارتدادا على هذا الخبر نعم اسعار
النفط يعني التاثيراتها يعني تمتد الى
باقي الامور الاقتصاديه كذلك حول العالم
ما الذي يتوقع كذلك فيما يتعلق بالاجراءات
الاقتصاديه واعني هنا
بالتحديد مساله اسعار الفائده او سعر
الفائده من الفيدرالي الامريكي ماذا نتوقع
عند هذه النقطه بالذات
نعم
الفتره القادمه حتى رئيس الفيدرالي
الامريكي ايضا كان مترددا في جزم في اذا
كان سيستمر في رفع اسعار الفائده او انه
سيتوقف اعتبارا من منتصف العام الحالي
ويبدا بخفض هذه الاسعار الان هو مصمم
الفتره الامريكي على خفض التضخم الى اثنين
بالمئه اسعار مرتفعه للنفط لا تقدم هذا
الاتجاه بالنسبه للفتره الامريكيه لكن
اعتقد بانه ايضا قراءه الازمه المصرفيه
العالميه حجم النشاط الاقتصادي في الصين
الاقتصاد العالمي بشكل كامل الذي يتلقى
ضربات لم يتلقاها في القدم في الماضي لذلك
يصعب التنبؤ في نتائجها لذلك الان المتوقع
والغموض يلف الاقتصاد العالمي من جميع
النواحي وهذا جاء هذه الخطوه جاءت
احترازيه لمواجهه كم الهائل من عدم اليقين
في الاقتصاد العالمي عامر الشبكي الب في
شؤون النفط والطاقه من عمان شكرا جزيلا لك
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
بموازاه المدافع حرب نفسيه ومعنويه محتدمه
بين موسكو وكيف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخبار الساعه
ومشاهدينا نذهب مباشره الى هذه الصور التي
وصلتنا للتو من المزه في العاصمه السوريه
دمشق نشاهد السنه اللهب تتصاعد من سياره
اذا بعد سماعه عدوي انفجارات قويه اذا في
محيط مطار المزه العسكري جنوب غربي
العاصمه السوريه دمشق وكان قبل قليل حديث
عن انفجار سياره اذا جراء عبوه ناسفه في
منطقه المزه هذه السياره على ما يبدو التي
نشاهدها في هذه الصور الاوليه التي وصلتنا
من العاصمه السوريه دمشق
نتابع اذا هذه السياره وهي مشتعله نحاول
ان نستمع اذا كان هناك صوت طبيعي للفيديو
اذا مشاهدينا بالاضافه الى انفجار هذه
السياره
بعبوان ناسفه ايضا في المسجد في العاصمه
السوريه دمشق كان هناك شهود عيان نقلوا
رؤيه رز سماع دويا انفجارات قويه ايضا في
محيط مطار المزه العسكري جنوب غربيه
العاصمه السوريه دمشق كذلك وكانت هناك
انباء عن
قصف كذلك على ما يبدو
للعاصمه السوريه دمشق لمحيط مطار العاصمه
السوريه كذلك دمشق هذا المساء هذه اذن اخر
المعلومات التي حصلنا عليها اذن سنوافيكم
بالمزيد من المعلومات حاله توافرها اذا عن
تطورات هذا الوضع وهذه الانفجارات في
العاصمه السوريه دمشق
تم قبل قليل استدعاء مروحيات ومقاتلات
حربيه تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي في اعقاب
رصد مسيره مجهوله تسللت من جهه الاراضي
السوريه الى داخل الاجواء الاسرائيليه وتم
اسقاط المسيره في منطقه مفتوحه حيث لم
تشكل اي خطر في ايه مرحله ولم يتم تفعيل
الانذار
هذا التطور ياتي غدا اعلان ايران عن مقتل
ضابط ثاني من ضباط الحرس الثوري في قصف
تقول انه اسرائيلي استهدف محيط العاصمه
السوريه دمشق متعهده بالرد في الوقت
والمكان المناسبين في وقت تكثف اسرائيل من
هجماتها على القواعد الايرانيه في سوريا
بقصف تقول انه اسرائيلي استهدف محيط
العاصمه السوريه دمشق مقداد مقداني قتل
متاثرا بجراحه التي اصيب بها بقصف فجر
الجمعه الفائت ليكون ثاني قتيلا من ضباط
الحرس الثوري في القصف نفسه بعد مقتل
ميلاد حيدري الذي اعترفت طهران بمقتله في
وقت سابق خلال الشهر الاخير كثفت اسرائيل
من عملياتها الجويه في سوريا امتدت
الاستهدافات خلالها من جنوب البلاد الى
اقصى شمالها هجوم الاحد في حمص استهدف
قاعده تيفور الجويه قرب تدمر ومطار الضبعه
القريب من القصير الهجوم الجديد يعتبر
الثالثه خلال اسبوع بعد قصف مشابه على
ليلتين متتاليتين في الثلاثين والحادي
والثلاثين من مارس كذلك فان مقتل الضابطين
قرب دمشق جاء في قصف يعتبر السادس من نوعه
خلال اذار المنصرم سبقته هجمات على حلب
وحماه
الخارجيه الايرانيه وعلى لسان المتحدث
باسمها ناصر كناني توعد برد مناسب في
المكان والوقت المناسبين كلام كررته طهران
كثيرا بينما تقول اسرائيل ان من يستهدف
امنها سيدفع ثمنا باهظا
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اثمار
انه مستعد ان يكون الحرس الوطني تحت
قيادته او بقياده مفوض الشرطه فيما عبر
مفوض الشرطه يعقوب شبتاي عن مخاوفه اذا
هذه القوه الجديده في رساله الى بنجبير
حسبما ذكرت وسائل الاعلام المحليه وقال
المفوض انها نشر قوه الحرس الوطني سيستغرق
شهورا وانه يحاول دعم مراكز الشرطه
بالتوازي كما عبر شبتاي عن مخاوفه من ان
يكون مشروع قوه الحرس الوطني مكلفا جدا بل
ويضر بامن المواطنين
تصريحات بنج بير تاتي بعد مصادقه الحكومه
على انشاء حرس وطني تم الاعلان انه سيكون
موازي للشرطه والجيش الاسرائيلي وسيتكون
من مجموعه من الفرق الخاصه للسيطره على
اماكن حساسه يصعب على الشرطه والجيش
السيطره عليها الحرس الوطني يستهدف جنودا
سابقين وسيتم تدريبهم لتشكيل فرق تفرض
سيطرتها على الشارع اضافه الى تعديل بعض
القوانين وحل بعض المشاكل الداخليه في
اسرائيل واشارت صحف عبريه الى ان تكلفه
انشاء الحرس الوطني الاسرائيلي ستكون ضمن
ميزانيه وزاره الامن القومي التي حصل
عليها اثمار بن جرير لعام 2023
بمبلغ تسعه مليارات شيكل اي ما يعادل
2.5 مليون دولار امريكي
وبعد موافقه الحكومه الاسرائيليه على
تقليص الميزانيه الوزارات لصالح الحرس
الوطني قال زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا
ايرلافيد ان الحكومه قامت بهذه الخطوه
لتمويل ميليشيا بنجفير وان اولويات
الحكومه سخيفه وحقيره على حد وصفه
وافقت الحكومه على تخفيضات لتمويل
ميليشيات سوف يقتطعون من ميزانيه الصحه
والتعليم والامن وكل ذلك لتمويل جيش خاص
من السفاحين لمتطرف مهووس اولويات هذه
الحكومه سخيفه وحقيره الشيء الوحيد الذي
يبقيها مشغوله هو تجاوز الديمقراطيه
وتعزيز الاوهام المتطرفه للاشخاص
المهووسين
معنى من القدس
المحلل السياسي سيد شلومو اهلا بك كيف
تنظر الى تشكيل هذا الحرس الوطني في
اسرائيل واقتطاع ميزانيته من وزارات اخرى
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
قرار الحكومه هو قرار مبدئي ويتعين على
لجنه خاصه ما مؤلفه من اجهزه الامن
المختلفه بما فيها الشرطه ان تقدم توصيتها
خلال ثلاثه اشهر اي ان هذا الحرس عند ما
اذا تم
اقامته سيستغرق وقتا طويلا اشهر وربما هذا
سيكون بمثابه
التلبيه
للحملات الانتخابيه التي قام بها
اثناء الحمله الانتخابيه
والاكتفاء بذلك اعتقد بان ماذا تعرضت له
هذه الفكره
بالانتقادات سواء من داخل الحكومه وايضا
من قبل المعارضه وداخل الشرطه ومن اجهزه
الامن المختلفه وايضا من المستشار
القانونيه للحكومه اي ان هناك انتقاد شامل
فني هل تلمح السيد
هذه القوه قوه الحرس الوطني هو فقط يعني
مجامله بنكير لكي يحقق شعاراته الانتخابيه
بمعنى انه في الحقيقه في نهايه المطاف لا
يتم اقرار تشكيل هذه القوه الحرس الوطني
ام ماذا
علينا نشكر بان القرار وطرح هذا المشروع
هذا اليوم في بجلسه مجلس الوزراء نتيجه
الردوق رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو للابتزاز
السياسي الذي مارسه عليه
في الاسبوع الماضي حيث هدد
بتفكيك الائتلاف الحكومي والانسحاب منه
اذا لم
يستجيب
لهذا الطلب بتاسيس هذا الحكومه من جهه
ثانيه هذا الحرس
يشكل مشكله بالنسبه لاجهزه الامن المختلفه
وايضا بالنسبه لسائر الوزارات المختلفه
التي كل
ميزانياتها بصوره كبيره مما سيضر مستوى
الخدمات المقدمه للمواطنه الاسرائيلي سواء
في مجال التعليم الصحه والشؤون الاجتماعيه
وهذا ايضا طبعا لا يضمن بان
الوطني او القومي سيحقق جميع المال المعلق
عليه اي الضمان
الامن الذاتي
ومنع الجريمه في الوسط العربي وايضا منع
الجريمه في المجال الزراعي اعتقد بان هذه
المهام هي كبيره جدا وهي تتناقض مع مهام
الشرطه وربما اقامه هذا الجهاز سيكون على
حساب الشرطه وسائر الاجهزه الامنيه
الموجوده في صيد
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك من القدس
[موسيقى]
الحرب لا تدور فقط في ساحات المعارك بل ان
جزءا كبيرا منها يظهر في الكواليس ويرتكز
بالاساس على العاملين النفسي والاستراتيجي
وليس الحربي فقط والحال لا يختلف في الحرب
الاوكرانيه فما هي الحيل التي يستخدمها كل
طرف في هذه الحرب المواسيه صحيفه تانجا
البريطانيه سلطت الضوء على ما وصفته
المعركه النفسيه والاستراتيجيه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا فبالنسبه لروسيا تقول الصحيفه
ان التهديد باستخدام السلاح النووي كان
المناوره السياسيه الاكثر وضوحا وتقول
الصحيفه ان بوتين يرغب فقط في اثاره قلق
المعسكر الغربي لدفعهم الى الضغط على كيف
من اجل فتح مفاوضات للسلام ومن بين الحيل
النفسيه التي تستخدمها موسكو ايضا تقول
الصحيفه هي عمليه التجنيد وهي خطه ترمي
الى اخافه اوكرانيا وحلفائها فقط وليس
بسبب وجود حاجه حقيقيه
وكما هو الحل بالنسبه لموسكو فان الوضع لا
يختلف بالنسبه للكياف التي استعملت الكثير
من الخدع النفسيه والاستراتيجيه منذ بدايه
الحرب وتقول الصحيفه ان اوكرانيا تقوم
بشكل دوري بتعديل قواتها خلف خط المواجهه
لمنع موسكو من الحصول على تفاصيل دقيقه عن
خطاطها كما ان اوكرانيا تعمد الى تشتيت
القوات الروسيه من خلال نشر معلومات
مغلوطه حول نيتها استهداف منطقه محدده
وذلك من اجل جذب الجنود الروسي لتقوم
بعدها باستهداف منطقه اخرى كما حدث قبلا
في خاركس
[موسيقى]
قطاع العملات المشفره في بريطانيا يختنق
رغم محاولات انعاشه من طرف حكومه رئيس
الوزراء ريشيسوناك فجهود الاخير في جعل
البلاد مركزا عالميا للعملات المشفره
اصطدمت بتعنت واضح من البنوك الكبرى في
بريطانيا فنقلا عن موقع الامريكي فان
العديد من البنوك البريطانيه الكبرى فرضت
مزيدا من القيود على مقدار الاموال التي
يمكن للعملاء تحويلها الى بورصات الاصول
الرقميه كما ترفض هذه البنوك انشاء حساب
المصرفي للشركات الناشئه في قطاع التشفير
وتحتاج هذه الشركات الناشئه الى البنوك
التقليديه في معاملاتها بشكل عام سواء
لانشاء حسابات بنكيه او لمبادله العمله
الورقيه باصول رقميه ودفع سوق الخدمات
المصرفيه بعض الشركات قطاع التشفير الى
التقدم بشكوى مباشره الى حكومه هذا وتراجع
راس المال للاستثماري في شركات الاصول
الرقميه في المملكه المتحده بنسبه 94%
مقارنه بالعام السابق
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه قلق عالميه من
تحول فيروس ماربورك الى جائحه جديده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لا علاج له مميت خطير
وسريع الانتشار نتحدث هنا عن فيروس مار
بورد الذي يثير انتشاره حاله من الفزع
عالميا فهو يتسبب بحمى نزفيه شديده العدوى
بحسب مراكز السيطره على الامراض الامريكيه
وهو من عائله فايروس ايبولا وكلاهما لديه
القدره على التسبب في معدلات وفيات عاليه
بين المصابين الصحه العالميه قالت ان
معدلات الوفيات بين المصابين بفيروس مار
بورد تتراوح بين 24 الى 88 بالمئه وفقا
لحالات الانتشار السابقه وتعرف العلماء
لاول مره على هذا الفيروس عام 67 عندما
انتشر بين عمال المختبرات في ماربورج
وفرانكفورت بالمانيا وفي بلغراد اثناء
اجراء البحوث على حيوانات تم استيرادها من
اوغندا
ورغم ان هذا الفيروس لا ينتقل عبر الهواء
فانه ينتشر بسرعه من خلال الاتصال المباشر
بين البشر خاصه المرتبطين بالسوائل مثل
الدم او اللعاب او البول ويمكن حتى لجثث
المصابين ان تبقى معديه عند الدفن ووفقا
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه تقدر فتره الحضانه
للاصابه بالفيروس بين ثلاثه الى تسعه ايام
وتبدا اعراضه بالاصابه بالصداع حاد ووعكه
شديده والام عضليه وتشمل ايضا حمى شديده
وايضا وهن تدريجي وسريع اسهال حاد والم في
البطن وغثيان وتقيؤ يمكن ان يدوم اسبوعا
استمرار الاصابه تؤدي الى اصابه الجهاز
العصبي في الحالات المميته تحدث الوفاه في
اليوم الثامن او التاسع بعد الاصابه
ويرى معظم المختصين ان الوقايه بشكل عام
من الحمى النزفيه المرتبطه بالفيروسات مثل
ما برج او ايبولا قد تكون امرا صعبا اذا
كنت تعيش في مناطق تنتشر فيها هذه الامراض
او تسافر اليها وعليك استخدام وسائل
الوقايه عند التعامل مع اي من سوائل الجسم
بارتداء قفازات وواقيات العين والوجه كما
يجب تجنب الحشرات خاصه البعوض
والجراد وعليك ارتداء السراويل الطويله
والاكمام الطويله واستخدام وسائل الحمايه
من البعوض كما عليك ايضا ابعاد القوارض عن
منزلك بوضع القمامه في حاويات مضاده
للقوارض والتخلص من النفايات بانتظام
والحرص على ان يكون للابواب والنوافذ
واقيات للحشرات
واذا كانت الوقايه صعبه فالعلاج لم يعتمد
بعد ويتلقى المصابون الرعايه الداعمه
وعلاجات للمضاعفات والجفاف تعمل على تحسين
معدلات البقاء على قيد الحياه وفق منظمه
الصحه العالميه وينصح بعض خبراء الصحه
العامه باستخدام الادويه المستخدمه في
العلاج من الاصابه بالايبولا ولكن حتى
الان لم تثبت التجارب السريريه نجاعه
الامر
[موسيقى]
صوره الملك تشارلز الثالث تثير الجدل بشكل
كبير والسبب الميزانيه الكبيره التي صرفت
في عمليات طباعتها وتوزيعها على الهيئات
العامه في البلاد وخارجها فقد تم تخصيص
ثمانيه ملايين جنيه استرليني لتوزيع
الالاف من الصور الرسميه للملك تشارلز على
مختلف المؤسسات الحكوميه في البلاد
وتدخل هذه العمليه في اطار التحضير لحفل
تتويج الملك شهر مايو القادم خطوه اثاره
انتقادات واسعه سيما في ظل الازمه الماليه
التي تعيشها البلاد منذ اشهر بسبب التضخم
الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز اخبارها
تراقب لمحاكمه ترامب في نيويورك بعد غد
والرئيس السابق يريد الوصول امام المحكمه
مقيدا استعراضا لقوته
تسع دول تعلن تخفيضا طوعيا بواقع مليون
و600 الف برميل النفط يوميا ابتداء من
مايو وحتى نهايه العام
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعترض مسيره انطلقت من
سوريا واجتازت الحدود الشماليه
رغم محاولات ريشيسوناك عاشه قطاع العملات
المشفره في بريطانيا يختنق بضغط من البنوك
شكرا لكم على كرم المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]